COMMITTEE.
TO ORDER THE HOUR OF FOR CLARK
KEVIN ARRIVED.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
THIS AFTERNOON.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING.
IS THE TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT.
THIS WAS EXECUTED ON AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BETWEEN GOVERNOR BROWN.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE A
CALIFORNIA. AND THE ELK VALLEY
RANCHERIA.
TODAY WE HEAR FOR THE PRINCIPAL
ARCHITECTS OF THIS COMPACT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS WELL AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE TRIBE.
THIS COMPACT AUTHORIZES TRIBE TO
OPERATE A MAXIMUM OF TWELVE
HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES HAD NO
MORE THAN TWO GAMING FACILITIES
LOCATED WITHIN THE EXISTING
INDIAN TRUST LANDS AS DEFINED.
THE ECONOMIC TERMS THE COMPAQ
REFLECT THE TRIBES SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE MARKET IN
WHICH THE TRIBE OPERATES ITS
GAMING FACILITY.
THE TRIBE IS AGREED TO PAY THE
STATE IT'S PRO RATA SHARE COST
THE STATE INCURS FOR THE
PERFORMANCE OF ITS DUTIES UNDER
THE COMPACT AS SPECIFIED.
TERMS OF THE COMPACT RELATED
LICENSING REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
LABOR OF PUBLIC SAFETY ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY THE SAME AS RECENT
COMPACT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HEARD.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
PROVISIONS WITHIN THE COMPACT
REAFFIRM THE TRIBE'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH AND PRIOR
COMMITMENTS TO DEL NORTE COUNTY.
WHAT'S EFFECTIVE THIS COMPACT
WILL BE IN FULL FORCE AND EFFECT
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOLLOWING
THE EFFECTIVE DATE.
I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
REMIND ALL THE INTERESTED
PARTIES THAT NO FORMAL VOTE WILL
BE TAKEN TODAY TODAY'S HEARING
IS.
FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO BE
BRIEFED ON THE CAN CONTENTS OF
THE COMPACT AS IT CANNOT BE
AMENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
TODAY THERE IS NO PENDING
RATIFICATION BILL PENDING
NEITHER HOUSE BUT AFTER THAT
PROCESS OCCURS IN ACTUAL
RATIFICATION BILL WILL BE TAKEN
UP FOR CONSIDERATION BY THE
ENTIRE. BODY ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
AT THIS TIME WILL GO AHEAD. AND
MOVE TO ITEM TWO ON THE AGENDA
WILL ASK OR MISTER JOE DILLON
SENIOR ADVISER FOR TRIBAL
NEGOTIATIONS OFFICE OF GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN TO. GO AHEAD AND
COME UP TO THE.
DYSON PRESENT THE OUR CONTENTS
OF THE COMPACT FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT THE.
TRAVELS TAKING COMPACT BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ELK
VALLEY RANCHERIA AS YOU
DESCRIBE.
.
CHAIRMAN THE COMPACT IS.
ESSENTIALLY VERY SIMILAR TO
MOST OF THE OTHER COMPACT THAT
WE'VE WORKED HARD TO TO RATIFY
WITH THE GUY TO THE PATIENT
PROTECTION AND.
LABOR REGULATORY OVERSIGHT IN
THE VAST MAJORITY BY THE
PROVISIONS WE HAVE WORKED HARD
WITH THE TRIBE HERE. UNDEVELOPED
TERMSTHAT DO REFLECT THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCE
THAT WE WERE OF FORTUNE ENOUGH
TO GO UP TO THE THE RANCHERIA TO
TO LOOK AT WHAT THE TRIBE HAS
DONE AND. AND SEE THE PRIDE THAT
THEY HAVE TAKEN IN DEVELOPING
THEIR EXISTING FACILITY IN THE
PLANTS THAT MADE FOR THEIR THEIR
FUTURE FACILITY ON THE MARK
RANCH PROPERTY WHICH IS JUST A
MILE SOUTH OF THEIR CURRENT.
.
GAMING FACILITY I THINK WHAT
IMPRESSED ME MOST I TH WAS WAS
HOW THEY JUST HAVE A COMMITMENT
TO DOING THINGS RIGHT WORKING
HARD WITH. EACH OF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ENSURE THAT NOT
ONLY DO THEY HAVEPROGRAMS IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THEIR MEMBERS BUT THEY THEY DO
THAT IN A WAY THAT. THAT ENSURES
THAT THEY'RE A GOOD NEIGHBOR TO
ALL THE RESIDENTS OF DON'T
COUNTY.
SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER DO I THINK
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND SAVE OUR
QUESTIONS FOR THE ANSWER IF
YOU'D REMAIN APPEAR TO TEST OUT
THIS TIME REMOVED ITEM. THREE ON
THE AGENDA WILL WELCOME.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE OUT FOUND
RANCHERIA DALE MILLER.
TO PRESENT.
ON THE COMPACT
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRAY AND
THE GOP MEMBERS.
I MY NAME IS DALE MILLER ON THE
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN FELT REALLY
RANCHERIA.
IT'S FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
INDIAN TRIBE.
IT'S LOCATED HER CRESCENT CITY
CALIFORNIA. BOX MONTHLY TWENTY
MILES FROM THE OREGON BORDER.
BUT BEEN A SEVEN HOUR DRIVE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO THE CRISIS.
WHEN I READ.
THE CRIMES RESERVATION.
WAS ORIGINALLY CREATED IN
NINETEEN OH NINE.
WHO WAS IT LEGALLY TERMINATED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY PURSUANT? TO THE
FEDERAL CALIFORNIA RANCHERIA
ACT.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THE
TRIBES RESTORED RECOGNITION
THROUGH DETAIL HARDWICK
LITIGATION.
WHEN THAT HAPPENED OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS TO TRY WORKED FORMALLY
REORGANIZE AND OFFICE
CONSTITUTION IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR.
CRIED CONSISTS OF EIGHTY EIGHT
MEMBERS.
OR PRIMARY LOADED LOCATED STILL
DOWN THERE COUNTY.
BUT DO TO THAT TERMINATION
PROCESS SOME MEMBERS MOVED AWAY.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE ONE MEMBER
IN FLORIDA.
TRIED OPEN THE KILL PHALLIC SEEN
ON NINETEEN NINETY FIVE.
THE ELK VALLEY CASINO CURRENTLY
OFFERS APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED SLOT MACHINES.
BLACKJACK AND POKER ALONG WITH A
SMALL RESTAURANT.
HE REALLY WAS TO DOUBLE WIDE
TRAILER SO WE STARTED.
THE TRIBE EMPLOYS APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY EMPLOYEES.
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED TWENTY
THEM EMPLOYED AT THE ACTUAL
CASINO ITSELF.
IT MAKES HELP RALLY ONE OF THE
LARGEST PRIVATE EMPLOYERS IN THE
COUNTY OF DON'T.
WHEN EL VALLEY RESORT CASINO IS
FULLY BUILT THE TRIBE
ANTICIPATES AN INCREASE TO
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED.
A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES.
DELMAR CARD COUNTY. IS.
HIGH POVERTY RATE AREA.
WHICH IS THAT TWENTY TWO POINT
FOUR PERCENT.
WHICH IS ALREADY CONSIDERABLY
HIGHER THE NATIONAL POVERTY RATE
OF FOURTEEN POINT EIGHT PERCENT.
LIKEWISE THE MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME. PREDELLA COUNTY IS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
DRIVERS DEVELOPED A PLAN TO
BUILD A RESORT AND CASINO. TO
INCREASE EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
IN THE COUNTY.
AND TO DRAW MORE VISITORS TO THE
COUNTY.
THIS PROJECT OF COMMUNITY WIDE
IMPORTANCE.
WAS DELAYED DUE TO THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN.
THE COUNTY'S POOR ECONOMIC
SITUATION IS ONLY RECENTLY
SINGING.
A MUCH DELAYED RECOVERY.
AT FULL BUILD OUT THEY'LL
THEY'LL THEY'LL RESORT CASINO IS
EXPECTED TO ATTRACT SIX HUNDRED.
FORTY THOUSAND VISITORS IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF OPERATION.
THE MOU BETWEEN A COUNTY IN A
CRIED COVERS A FULL RANGE OF
MUNICIPAL SERVICES.
LONG FORCE MEANT IN THE TRIBE
COVERS AYE PROSECUTIONS.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SERVICES FIRE
PROTECTION.
SEWER AND WATER SERVICES.
THE MOU PROVIDES FOR ESCALATING
ANNUAL PAYMENTS.
ESTIMATED TO BE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND HOW ADDITION A PROJECT
EXPECTED TO GENERATE ADDITIONAL
LOCAL AND STATE TAXES OF
PROBABLY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
DUE TO CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES
IN BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM INCREASED ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
ASSOCIATED. WITH RESORT
OPERATIONS IN THE COUNTY.
THE TRIBE IS A GOOD PARTNER TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE TO
TRY HAS ENTERED INTO ENORMOUS
NUMBERS MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
TO ADDRESSED EMERGENCY SERVICES
FIRE PROTECTION. LAW ENFORCEMENT
WATER SEWER AND ROAD PROJECT
PROJECTS AMONG OTHERS.
OVER THE LAST YEAR THE TRIBE IS
CONDUCTED PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
PLEASE THESE PROJECTS TOTALING
NEARLY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO.
WE'LL BE REHABILITATION OF THE
CRESCENT CITY FIRE HALL IN
PURCHASE OF A NEW TYPE ONE FIRE
ENGINE.
THUS IMPROVING THE SAFETY OF THE
COMMUNITY. AN IMPROVING
FIREFIGHTING CAPACITY.
SEWER LIFT STATION IMPROVEMENTS
FOR DOWN OUR COUNTY MAKING THE
SEWER SYSTEM MORE EFFICIENT.
AND THE FRANK COST THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE CHARGED TO COUNTY
CITY AND SPECIAL DISTRICT USERS.
HUMBLE RAY ROAD SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT.
RESULTING IN IMPROVE SAFETY IN
ROAD ALIGNMENT HUMBLE ROAD IN
SAN MINE WROTE. RESULTING IN
IMPROVED ALIGNMENT AND SAFETY OF
THAT INTERSECTION.
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW ASSISTANCE
FOR THE JACK MCNAMARA.
THEREFORE.
IN ADDITION.
THE TRIBE MATES SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DIRECT
DONATIONS TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY FOR YOU SPORTS.
LONG FOR SMITH SOCIAL SERVICES
ARTS SAFETY EMERGENCY NEEDS SIX
CETERA.
I CRIED CONTINUES TO UTILIZE
GAMING REVENUES TO PROVIDE.
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO OUR
TRIBAL MEMBERS.
I HEALTHCARE INSURANCE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE.
CULTURAL AND RESOURCE
PROTECTION.
IN OTHER SERVICES FOR TRIBAL
MEMBERS.
THE TRIBE FUNDS EDUCATIONAL
ASSISTANCE IN TO READ FOR GRADE
SCHOOL.
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WE
FUND HIGHER EDUCATION TUITION
FOR A CITIZENS ALSO.
NUMEROUS TRIBAL MEMBERS HAVE
OBTAINED VARIOUS VOCATIONAL.
ASSOCIATE AND BACHELOR'S
DEGREES.
ASSISTANT WITH THEIR GOALS.
WE BELIEVE THAT EDUCATION IS THE
KEY TO OUR ONGOING.
AND FUTURE SUCCESS
LIKEWISE WE PROVIDE HEALTHCARE
INSURANCE TO OUR CITIZENS AS
LACK OF INSURANCE WOULD
OTHERWISE LIMIT ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. HEALTHCARE.
CARTWRIGHT APPRECIATION
GOVERNOR'S BROWN'S WILLINGNESS
TO NEGOTIATE A NEW COMPACT TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE UP RALLY RANCHERIA.
THIS NEW COMPACT LYSIS TO TRIED
TO MAKE ITS RESORT PROJECT A
REALITY. AND BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
THAT PARTICULAR RESORT HAS BEEN
EIGHTEEN YEARS AND WORK.
TRIBE IS PROUD TO BE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE DONOR COUNTY
COMMUNITY. THE TRIBES EFFORT AT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OCCLUDING
THE CURRENT HEALTH WELL A
CASINO.
IN FUTURE ELK VALLEY RESORT AND
CASINO. INCREASES REGIONAL
TOURISM. CREATES NEW BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND INCREASES
COMMERCIAL REAL RECREATIONAL
FOR ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
NOT JUST TO TRY.
WE BELIEVE THE COMPAQ REFLECTS
THE LOGICAL BALANCE OF STATE AND
TRIBAL INTERESTS AND RECOGNIZES
THE TRIBE. CRIES PRODUCTIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH COUNTY OF DEL
MAR AND CRESCENT CITY.
PERSONALLY WOULD LIKE THAT THANK
JOE DOLAN AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING FOR US IS SERVICE. ALONG
HONG.
LEADERSHIP BUT WE CAN.
SURE WE SURE HAPPY WITH THAT.
WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR
COMPACT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY REGARDING COMPACT
HEALTHILY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE.
YOU BEING HERE TODAY.
TO SHARE YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
OUR TERMS TO COMPACT BEFORE.
THE COMMITTEE IN THE HOUSE.
AGAIN MEMBERS WERE GOING TO SAVE
OUR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. FOR
THE END OF THIS TIME REMOVED
ITEM FOR THE AGENDA.
JACOBIN IS NOT HERE ALSO VERY
BROAD IS GOING TO PINCH HIT FOR
HIM.
VERY MUCH LIKE TO COME UP AND.
.
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE THE
WISDOM AND WIT YOU HAVE ON THIS
PARTICULAR CONTACT BEFORE US.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS VERY BROAD ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED HERE.
LISTA. THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND
MISTER DILLON FOR OUR.
INCLUDING IN THIS COMPACT IN
AGREEING TO THE PROVISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN SOME. MANY OF THE
OTHER COMPACTS ALMOST ALL THE
OTHER CONTACTS.
THAT.
ALLOW.
WORKERS TO ORGANIZE UNIONS IN
AN ATMOSPHERE OF.
NEUTRALITY AND.
WEEKLY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT
THE POSITIVE ATTITUDE. UP OF
THIS TRIBE AND WISH THEM THE
BEST OF LUCK.
ON.
GETTING THIS RESORT.
UP AND RUNNING AFTER EIGHTEEN
YEARS.
AND I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO MOVE TO OUR FINAL ITEM ON THE
AGENDA WHICH IS PUBLIC COMMENT.
TRANNY.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT THERE'S A MICROPHONE. IN
THE AISLE PLEASE.
APPROACH AND PRESENT YOUR
COMMENTS.
SUSAN JOHNSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF SEEN I GO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS COMPACT THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIEL BRENTON
AND I'M A UNION CARPENTER I
WANTED TO TAKE A SECOND TO THANK
YOU FOR.
YOU'RE CAREFUL CONSIDERATION ON
THIS.
.
THE CARPENTERS UNION HAS BEEN A
LONG STANDING PARTNER AND HAS IT
HAD A GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH HELP VALLEY RANCHERIA YEAH
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THE
LOCAL JOB CREATION AND
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
DAD DOT THAT THEY REPRESENT.
YOUR REGARDING SUPPORT TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS THROUGH UNION WAGES
AND BENEFITS MEANS REAL CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR.
.
NATIVE AMERICANS FOR WOMEN.
AND FOR AYE OTHER MINORITIES
THIS IS AN ECONOMIC STIMULUS TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND WITH
PERMANENT BENEFITS
A CHANCE TO EMPOWER PEOPLE WITH
DIGNITY AND THE ABILITY TO EARN.
A MIDDLE CLASS LIVING. LOT I
HOPE THAT YOU STAND WITH US IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME.
SEE NINE WILL GO AHEAD AND.
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERSHIP
CARD FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS.
WHICH GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE QUESTION.
CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN HOW
ABOUT THE LABOR PROVISIONS.
.
ARE SIMILAR TO THOSE RECENTLY IN
THE COMPAQ.
YES SIR THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THIS CONTRACT IS
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL TO ALL OF
THOSE THAT WE'VE NEGOTIATED. ARE
OTHER.
CONTACTS THAT.
THE SILVER CHOSEN FIFTEEN IS
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME SLIGHT
TWEAKS BUT NOTHING MATERIAL
THERE SIGNIFICANT.
.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN.
THE BASIC PROVISIONS OF THAT
ORDINANCE HAVE BEEN THE SAME.
.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
CLARIFICATIONS IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I THINK
THOSE WERE CARRIED OVER HERE BE
GLAD TO GO OVER THOSE WITH YOU
BUT WE DON'T BELIEVE THE TRIBE
DIDN'T BELIEVE IN. THE LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THOSE CLARIFICATION.
DID ANYTHING TO CHANGE THE
BENEFITS TO BOTH PARTIES FROM
THAT ANOTHER SOURCE INTO HIS EX
REMAINS CONSISTENT THAT'S RIGHT
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION I
DON'T A DOMINANT TIME. LITERALLY
THINKING.
ANY OTHER ARE QUESTIONS
ACCOMPLISH MEMBERS.
MISTER GORE. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
AND I SHOULD NOT THINK THAT BE
HERE TODAY FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
NOTED THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
RELATIVE TO THE LENGTH OF TIME
YOU'VE BEEN. ENDEAVORING TO GET
THE RESORT UP ASSUMING THAT THIS
COMPACT BE RATIFIED. BY MAGIC.
THAT'S NOT THE END OF IT I
MAGICALLY CONSEQUENTIAL
AVAILABLE FOR WITH PROJECT.
BUT.
BUT THEY'RE PROBABLY SOME OTHER
AYE CHALLENGES THAT YOU FOR C.
I'M CURIOUS OF WHAT OTHER
BARRIERS SCENE OR UNFORESEEN
THAT YOU CAN ANTICIPATE FOR THE
COMPLETION OF YOUR REGAINING
PROJECT.
WE'RE HOPING THAT.
.
AGAIN I.
I'M REAL CAREFUL ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THAT WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED THIS PROJECT EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO I GOT OUR COMMUNITY
WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE AND.
I SPEND A LOT OF TIME IN VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS SPEAKING ABOUT HOW
THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN AND IT
NEVER DID HAPPEN BECAUSE
ECONOMY BUT.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE WE'RE HOPING TO
GET.
EVERYTHING GOT IT STARTED THIS
THIS SUMMER TAKES ABOUT FIFTEEN
MONTHS I BELIEVE THE FINISHED
PROJECT.
AND.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU'RE
FAMILIAR THEY'RE BUILT RIGHT ON
HIGHWAY ONE ON ONE AND RIGHT ON
THE.
SO.
IT IF THIS WONDERFUL PROJECT
IT'S IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND AND THAT.
.
WE IT DOES A LOT OF THINGS FOR
THE TRIBE SO WE CAN CONTINUE ON
THE BE.
INVOLVED IN OUR COMMUNITY.
IF YOU EVER COME UP SEE OUR
OFFICE YOU'LL SEE A BIG THING
WITH OUR MISSION STATEMENT. AND
IT'S ALWAYS INCLUDED THE
COMMUNITY.
BESIDES OURSELVES.
.
THEY THEY APPRECIATE IT MAKES
FOREST'S.
LET'S NOT A GIVEAWAY LOCATION.
AGAIN ASSUMING PASSAGE OF THE
COMPACT.
ITSELF LIKE YOU CAN GET UNDER
WAY SO YOU HAVE.
THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
SOMETHING SOME FOLKS WHO WON'T
HELP YOU BUILD IT.
SO WE THIS IS THIS FOR FAR YOU
COULD SEE THIS POINT KNOCK ON
WOOD RECOGNIZE IN RECENT YEARS
BUT NOT IN THE. SERVICE
INDUSTRY.
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE BUT
OTHERWISE IT YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
CAN PROCEED.
AFTER THIS COMPACT.
AND I GET THERE DIRECTIONAL AMMO
YOU WITH COUNTY WAS EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO.
INTO AND THAT THAT TIME I DON'T
KNOW WITH ANY TRIBE THAT.
IT'S A GREAT WELL I'M I
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON THE
COMMUNITY OF COURSE IT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT TO THOSE OF US THAT
OFFICER THE PLEASURE OF THE
COMMUNITY. ON AT THE SAME TIME
IT'S VERY POINT TO ME THE
ABILITY FOR TRIES TO BE SELF
RELIANT.
AND HAVE SELF DETERMINATION SO
I I WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK
WITH THIS PARTICULAR EFFORT.
OKAY TO HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
SEEING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAIR. ON.
MISSION DON'T HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU.
AND ACTUALLY BEFORE I GET INTO
THE QUESTION ON GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR RECOGNIZING THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR INCLUDES
OTHER MONTHS OTHER THAN AUGUST.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT.
.
IF YOU DOES QUICK ORDER YOU.
OF THE CURRENT SOLVENCY OF THE
REVENUE ASSURING TRUST FUND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE.
HE SERVED IN HEARING FROM YOU ON
THAT SUB.
YES SIR I I SHOULD TO GET THE
MORE PRECISE INFORMATION CHECK
WITH WITH THE FACT THAT THE
GAMMA CONTROL COMMISSION TO
MONITOR THE
MY UNDERSTANDING THE LAST TIME I
DID CHECK IN WITH THEM THAT THE
PROJECTIONS.
WERE THAT.
THE FUND WOULD HAVE
APPROXIMATELY.
.
ONE HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF FINES GOING TOWARDS
IT WHICH WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
FULLY MEET THE OBLIGATIONS OF
ONE POINT ONE MILLION TO HE SAID
THAT.
ARTIST YOU HAVE ELIGIBLE TRIBES
AND THEN TO HAVE MONEY AVAILABLE
FOR PLACEMENT INTO THE TRIBAL
NATION GRAND FUN.
GIVEN THAT THE THE MONEY COMING
FROM OTHER TRIBES THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTING INTO THE FUND.
PROVIDE FOR THAT SO.
.
THE THE ARTIST YOU HAVE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN ITS HISTORY IS IS
FULLY SOLVENT. AND ABLE TO DO
THE VERY IMPORTANT THINGS OF
ENSURING THAT TRIBES LIKE ELK
VALLEY RANCHERIA. OF HAVE
SUPPORT THAT COMES FROM THOSE
OTHER TRIBES THAT JUST HAPPENED
TO BE LOCATED IN A AND A LOOK.
PLACE THAT THE GENERATES
ADDITIONAL REVENUE THROUGH
THEIR.
FOR THEIR GIMMICK FACILITIES SO
I THINK THE FUND LOOKS PRETTY
GOOD NOW IT ALL THE MORE REASON
WHY. I WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
SPONSORING TO PROVIDE THE
DETAILS FOR THE GOT TO THE
MECHANISM ENSURING THAT THE THE
MONEY THAT GOES INTO THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANT FUND.
GETS TO THE. THE TRIBES THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR IN A WAY THAT HAS
LEGITIMACY IN THE EYES OF ALL
TRIBES THOSE WHO CONTRIBUTED
THOSE WHO RECEIVE.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT. MACHERLA THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR TENNIS Y. DAY AND.
CONGRADULATIONS IT YOURSELF AND
TRY BUT OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF WORK
IN MANY YEARS HAVE GONE INTO
THIS EFFORT. AND AS STATED
EARLIER THIS.
IT WILL ULTIMATELY PUT IN THE
CONTENTS OF THE BILL AND HER
BEFORE THE WHOLE BODY ON THE.
FOREIGN.
WE WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK
AND WITH THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS JOURNAL